[Music]
in part two of the story the finder
which is the first story in ursula k's
fifth earth sea book tales from earthsea
were introduced to a
wizard gaelic who in certain respects is
stereotypical
and
particularly for his time and in other
respects is a bit of an outlier as we're
going to see
he's described as looming above young
otter gaelic wore fantastic clothes as
many of his kind did in those days a
long robe of larbonnery silk scarlet
embroidered in gold and black with runes
and symbols and a wide brim peak-crowned
hat made him seem taller than a man
could be
otter did not need to see his clothes to
know him he had knew the hand that had
woven his bonds and cursed his knights
and then gaelic says i think i found my
little finder he's being very you know
clever there his voice was deep and soft
like the notes of a veal and we find out
that his his voice is sonorous and
weedling and one of his instruments that
he uses and who is this guy so
gaelic is officially the wizard of the
king who's laid claim to hovnor he's not
a real king he's basically a slaver and
a pirate
a warlord his name is lawson
and gaelic has as we find out later on
an apprentice early who will replace
gaelic after gaelic comes to a bad end
for
uh again the the king uh lolsin who
wants to use these wizards to do things
for him right
and
gaelic is in a particular area he moves
around from place to place he has to go
see the king and then he comes back to
where otter has been after he's captured
been taken
and he's surrounded the entire area with
spells there's some very interesting
descriptions about these almost like
vast networks and they keep
not only the prisoners the other
prisoners who are enslaved and working
on things stuck where they are so if
they tried to escape bad things would
happen to them but it also keeps the
young otter or medra who's going to
become eventually a mage and who has
magical talent keeps him confined keeps
him unable to use his magic to say
change himself into an otter and escape
and it turns out
that these spells are so complete
that um gaelic
is actually unused to having other
people talk to him unless he asks them
questions there's this very interesting
scene
he pants on her shoulder i know you have
the gift of finding what's hidden quite
a great gift where it's suitably trained
have no fear my son i know why you led
my servants only to the little load
playing and delaying but now that i've
come you serve me and have nothing to be
afraid of and there's no use trying to
conceal anything from me the wise child
loves his father and obeys him and the
father rewards him as he deserves he
leaned very close as he liked to do and
said gently confidentially i'm sure you
can find the great lobe and then the
person who
otter is connected with anieb one of the
slaves working in the smelter says i
know where it is
then it's very interesting very few
people ever spoke to gaelic unless he
compelled them to
the spells by which he silenced weakened
and controlled all who approached him
were so habitual to him that he gave
them no thought he was used to being
listened to but not to listening serene
in his strength and obsessed with his
ideas he had no thought beyond them he
was not aware of honor at all except as
a part of his plans an extension of
himself yes yes you will he said and
smiled again this is a person who has so
much power
compared to everybody else around him
and has been exerting it so long
that he he can't see when other people
are
slipping the net as a matter of fact
there's a point where he's he that
little boy is up to something
and he doesn't pay enough attention to
it
what is gaelic focused on well he's
obsessed with mercury
the element the substance and why
well
he has found a book and this book
is going to
give him something that he can
develop something that's going to set
him apart from the other wizards here's
a description
of late and entering always deeper into
the mysteries of a certain lore book
brought back from the isle of way by one
of losing's raiders gaelic had become
indifferent to most of the arts
he had learned or had discovered for
himself the book convinced him that all
of them were only shadows or hints of a
greater mastery as one true element
controlled all substances one true
knowledge contained all others
approaching ever closer to that mastery
he understood the crafts of wizards were
as crude and false as lozen's title and
rule when he was one with a true element
he would be the one true king alone
among men would he speak the words of
making and unmaking he would have
dragons for his dogs
and going on a little bit further
in this
in the lore book from way were passages
concerning the true refiners fire having
long studied these gaelic knew that once
he had enough of the pure metal
the next stage was to refine it yet
further into the body of the moon so
it's not just mercury that he wants
it's mercury itself as a raw material to
transform into this this other magical
substance the body of the moon which
then he will be able to
use this purified quicksilver to become
himself
the
all-king
and he's got an operation set there to
mine and refine mercury from ore the
refining operation itself in in the
cooker is taking slaves who only last a
year or two there at the most because of
the fumes from the mercury and the ill
treatment otherwise ania is one of those
slaves and otter gets to see this and to
to connect with her
telepathically as it turns out
um
all of these slaves are busy making the
heat that then refines the mercury
in you know from the ore the cinnabar
into little tiny droplets which is what
gaelic is after
and medra is being used as a finder
something that gaelic views as a base
art something he doesn't have to indulge
in himself but he can get this young man
to do it and what it means to be a
finder in the case of of the earth is
being able to tell what's beneath you so
he can tell where there's water he can
tell where there's iron ore and he can
tell where there is the mercury or the
cinnabar or the red mother as gaelic is
going to call it in his mystical way
so
you know
otter has found a small amount of it
barely worth refining as gaelic says
and he can also lead uh
if there is a mother load
lead gaelic to the mother lode where
then he can get enough of the mercury to
do what he wants
so
what's all this about mercury what
what's going on here um you know this is
being discussed in that
lore book but gaelic himself is going
beyond that considerably
and he tells
um
here we go
he's taking
otter into his confidence and he says do
you know the king i'm talking about do
you know his name otter says the water
metal so the vulgar call it or
quicksilver or water of weight
but those who serve him call him the
king the all-king and the body of the
moon
those who have learned to see truly can
see him as he is the lord of all
substances the root of power lies in him
do you know what we call him in the
secrecy of his palace would you like to
know i'll tell you
and so he says his name is tourist do
you know that name it's a word in the
language of the all king his own name in
his own language in our base tongue we
would say semen for he is seed and
fructifier the seed and source of might
and right you'll see come along you'll
see the king flying among his subjects
right so he's talking to otter and he's
like letting him in on his enthusiasm
his passion
mercury purified from the vile red
mother you can see a lot of misogyny
built into this or baked into this you
might say
and so
gaelic tells him
that you know here in the roasting pit
evil spirits that work for the king
become clean as they slather the dross
and stains flow out of them illness and
impurities fester and run free from
their sores when they're burned up at
last they can fly up into the courts of
the king really what he's doing is he's
just using up the slaves and killing
them with mercury poisoning but this is
how gaelic is is explaining it to him
um
and then he he tells us
give your dross to the fire it'll be
transformed into the living silver the
light of the moon is it not a wonderful
thing how from what is most base comes
what is most noble that is a great
principle of the art from the vile red
mother is born the all-king from the
spittle of a dying slave has made the
silver
seed of power so this is one of the key
principles for him that um
you you get the
the best things from taking the the
worst things and refining them operating
on them in certain ways and then there's
this interesting little vignette
where
he talks about the difference between
attitudes towards the mercury and
towards power
he says
to otter are you afraid of the king and
utter nods and then gaelic says if you
share his power he won't harm you to
fear a power to fight a power is very
dangerous to love power and share it is
the royal way and then he says look
watch what i do
he holds up a pouch in which he put the
few drops of quicksilver he unseals it
lifts it to his lips and drank its
contents
he opened his smiling mouth so otter
could see the silver drops pooling on
his tongue before he swallowed now
that's a dangerous thing to do we know
right
in in that time perhaps people didn't
quite understand that and then he says
this
now the king is in my body the noble
guest of my house he won't make me
slaver and vomit or cause sores on my
body for i don't fear him but invite him
and so he enters my veins and arteries
no harm comes to me my blood runs silver
i see things unknown to other men i
share the secrets of the king and when
he leaves me he hides in the place of
order and foulness itself and yet in
that vile place he waits for me to come
and take him up and cleanse him as he
cleans me so that each time we grow
purer together i am the one who shits
moonlight you will not know another such
and more than that more than that the
king enters into my seed he is my semen
i am tourist and he is me
and you know so if if
gaelic is actually right he's not only
refining it in the uh smelter but he's
also refining it within his own body and
gradually preparing himself to become
like the most powerful
wizard or mage or sorcerer ever by in
embracing the power
as it stands though
otter recognizes that gaelic isn't
everything that he's maintaining himself
to be
so
here we go
in all the time he was with gaelic he
tried to learn from him tried to
understand what the wizard was telling
him he was certain now that gaelic's
ideas the teaching he so eagerly
imparted
had nothing to do with his power with
any true power mining and refining were
indeed great crafts with their own
mysteries and masteries
but gaelic seemed to know nothing of
those arts
his talk of the all-king and the red
mother was mere words and not the right
words how did otter know that so here's
a key
instance right in all his flood of talaq
the only word gelat had spoken in the
old tongue the language of which wizard
spells were made was the word tourists
he said it meant semen
otter's own gift of major had recognized
that meaning was the true one
gelic had said the word also meant
quicksilver and otter knew he was wrong
his humble teachers had taught him all
they knew
all the words they knew of the language
of the making among them had been
neither the name of semen nor the name
of quicksilver but his lips parted his
tongue moved
eiser he said his voice was the voice of
the slave in the stone tower it was she
who knew the true name of quicksilver
and spoke it through him so this gives
otter hope that maybe he can actually
escape from gaelic and take ania the
slave with him as well
save her if she can be saved from
the damage that's being done to her body
through her work in the refining
operation
so what is gaelic he is indeed a very
powerful wizard
he is also crazy and he's gone way off
the path as even his apprentice as we
find later on in the story recognizes
he's gone insane and he's he's drawn to
this idea of refining mercury as the key
that will open up all power and dominion
and knowledge for him
as you know somebody who's
rivaling the beginning
uh
entity that created earth see segoy the
one who gave
words to things and raised the islands
up out of the deep as it turns out this
is all
nonsense a very powerful wizard
has gone deeply astray and is destroying
many people in the process coming back
to that thing from the lore book what we
find
is that um
here we go
there was always another meaning in the
the words of the lord perhaps the book
was saying there must be sacrifice not
only of base flesh but inferior spirit
the great fire in the tower should not
burn dead bodies but living ones living
unconscious purity from foulness bliss
from pain it was all part of the great
principle perfectly
clear once seen
and so he's thinking about what he's
going to do to these slaves a horrific
death a living death within the fire of
the tower smelting mercury so this is
this is this character gaelic who we see
come to a bad end and perhaps rejoice in
the bad end that he comes to
you